a CBS News medical contributor dr. David
agus is here with more on the worsening
pandemic David good morning we're less
than 60 days away from when most schools
would traditionally open and it's
becoming a contentious issue from a
medical perspective what needs to be the
main consideration in deciding how
schools will operate well there are a
lot of variables that go into a number
one by far and away is how many cases in
your area if you're an area with a
dramatically increasing casing in cases
it is difficult to consider opening
schools but you need to get the schools
ready you need to be able to social
distance you need to normalize wearing a
mask I can't say that enough kids will
have to wear a mask in school you may
have to change some of your class time
so that you can have fewer kids in the
class to social distance but it takes
resources and we have to work on it now
in preparation for September this week
in the case numbers but then the death
rate also was lower wasn't surging at
that level doctor foul she said not to
make too much of it that it's a false
narrative to make too much of that how
do we then put this into perspective why
this is a really important point I think
one that's normally misunderstood first
of all there's a delay from when you get
sick to when you die and then it could
be up to a four week delay from when you
die to their death certificate being
registered at the federal and state
level so that's a big delay number two
is we're getting better at treating
cases so the hospitalization rate is
going down number of people who get off
a ventilator is much much higher the
people who are younger who get it and
we're testing more so those four things
are the reason there's a change in the
death rate doctor we've seen a number
these states that have experienced
surges either pause they're reopening or
in some cases take a step back so
realizing it it's one nation sort of
with 50 different policies right now how
should states handle their reopening is
moving forward that's what's difficult
is that no matter where you walk in
different places have different policies
and so
the key is behavior if people are
wearing a mask in social distancing
cases will go down if they're not they
won't and so sometimes you have to enact
stricter rules in order to make that
happen
closing bars closing places where people
can get together and where the virus can
spread and so mayor's governors have to
step up and be aggressive here we have
to normalize behavior in order that this
virus doesn't spread if we all wear a
mask in three weeks there would be no
virus it's amazing to hear that to think
that people still aren't wearing a mask
but they are not the World Health
Organization issued a new report talking
about how the virus is spreading are we
learning more about the transmission
beyond obviously the wearing of masks so
the majority of spread in this country
is droplets which mask block there is
era civilization which is virus that can
stay in the air we don't know that's the
cause of spread or significant spread at
all but it is something that has taken
under advisement and the w-h-o says now
that it definitely is we don't know it's
causing but it will be studied and
that's a change in their policy but it's
not a major cause of spread right now in
the country oh hey dr. David agus thank
you once again very much